hello and welcome playing dog war one
devar one table problem okay usually a
place C form there are there are many
options this line with e4 I have played
sometimes in termina and tournament
chess over the board and quite
successfully I think black he does
equalize if he plays precisely but it is
some still a reasonably good line for
white it's very solid you can often get
a little bit of pressure by means of
this Queen b3 maneuver okay so probably
this first making e5 more difficult huh
yeah maybe he can simply take everything
like take b3 take f3 play e5
maybe 92 to C form something that often
oh it's quite good often I wonder about
this here and he's got 85 very very very
very quickly five I guess I have to stop
this
I mean I'm trading trading a lot lots of
pieces but
okay this is something that I don't mind
really
he's got this the bishop on g4 is in a
slightly awkward spot if I play Bishop
efore I can probably just play ff6 okay
I got a slight a slight pull why oh
really
why is that working okay I see it's got
disrupted to business
hmm interesting
I don't know I don't know what's best if
I take it I'm he see Scotty his key gets
to detune really okay I can go age three
take and then go back out so very little
okay I'm going for something else
I'm going for the bishop ending him one
reason to do this is the lack of time
this is something where I can play many
moves very quickly and it's not totally
straightforward equality I think for him
he's got those pawns here on on the
light squid maybe he manages money he
manages eight five in this position
which is which is going to be the key
move to equalize yeah okay yeah then I
then I've got absolutely nothing okay
maybe now I can try to invade
nice he's coming - coming - on you for
him slightly annoying William Kelly yeah
that was just nothing nothing at all
oops I missed that miss dad I think it's
still quite equal no not there to d3
it's probably it's okay there was I was
pretty stupid
he [ __ ] tricked me it's this is just
not good at all losing this this endgame
is really embarrassing every you just
start with the slight edge and you lose
it I took I took too long I really also
took far too long
Jim still lost him I can never get in
front of the pawn I hate this game I've
also also awful
[Applause]
therefore was probably probably a bad
decision after which you cannot cannot
do much I actually believed that like I
maybe have some ideas and because he's
on those squares but he always gets to
get gets to play a five and of course it
was a draw form form for the whole time
until I made the stupid stupid mistakes
[Music]
I should just just play for the draw
here and not try to do anything I mean
this is a dead dead position with you
you can screw it up as I proved yeah you
know just Bishop d1 hey this is just
yeah just have to be precise but I
wasn't
and now d5 I don't know and it's this
process is too late I guess and I don't
think there was any chance somewhere it
was just lost the whole time then I am
really unhappy them also like this
decision this is just better quiet
this f5 move is strong that is really a
strong move
I mean I thought the I thought the order
would not matter you know my Diaz is
like this this this and black is
suffering forever yeah and if I start
with this this is probably also true I
mean white is better here no doubt got
more space he's got no brakes and so on
but this is very strong
I mean my f4 is is leading to nothing -
really not leading to anything I thought
this could be an idea do this first and
go here
oh yeah here so here's okay if I was
super strong move very strong it's a
matter of move order really here I mean
I took a long time here because I've
looked at this this is threatening every
year trapping this basically but he can
go f6 and then I have to go to somewhat
weird square that that cost me so much
time I was trying to figure that out but
it's still kind of a cave I just go
ahead form but I didn't see five if I
was just very strong I mean the engine
ultimately wants to do this with a
fairly huge advantage you know yet the
problem is the combination of this in
connection with Bishop to c4 is going to
be annoying this is just not good plus
one is a fair assessment so this is
still stunned that he found e5 and so
it's really good yeah then I should just
be content with the drum I mean I can
just for for drawing him I should just
just stay in a Kia and if he goes a five
I cannot just sit no this is this is a
very clear way to just have no problems
at all but I was still somehow trying to
do something which is simply uncalled
for
okay guys thanks for watching